hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the second day of the world rapid
championship it's magnus carlton versus
youngshish of duda and it's a game that
really did not end as one would expect
simply because what was happening all
the time but uh as the title suggests it
most certainly did happen so let's check
it out and then we're gonna discuss it
uh a little bit more in the current
situation in the tournament so magnus
with the white pieces opens with e4 we
have c5 now do the ghosts for the
sicilian defense knight f3 and now
knight to f6 going after the e4 pawn uh
the so-called nymphs of each variation
of the sicilian with e5 by magnus knight
the d5 and now knights the c3 offering
black to double up a white spawns uh
duda goes for this knight captures the
captures and now knight to c6 and here
uh there are a couple of moves that are
very popular here like bishop for bishop
d3 bishop c4 but magnus goes for h4 and
it is not only as of move six uh already
as of move six that we have a completely
new game uh we have e6 due to continuous
development and bishop to f4 we have
queen to c7 uh and now the e5 point is
nicely defended so you don't have to
worry about this and the queen to d2
magnus signaling that he might be ready
to castle queen side with h6 and now
bishop to d3 uh we have b6 you have to
develop the light square bishop
somewhere and bishop to e4 now we have
bishop to b7 yeah and here magnus goes
for c for gaining more control over the
b5 and d5 squares and duda immediately
goes for the trade knight to a a5
offering a trade of light square bishops
magnus accepts this we have cactus
captures and now magnus castle's queen
side
we have queen to c6 and now at queen to
c3 we have bishop to e7 and now magnus
plays rook to d3 he wants to bring the
other rook to d1 and put a lot of
pressure along the d file but maybe a
little bit
more precise or at least it would
prevent duda from achieving what he did
uh would have been to maybe play rook to
e1 it would be slower but it would
prevent queen coming to e4 this is
exactly what duda does it's a very nice
centralizing move and from here the
queen does uh well uh just puts out a
lot of pressure the bishop is also being
threatened so b3 defending the g3
defending the bishop and knight to a5
now putting pressure on the c for pawn
and already because the queen was
allowed to e4 this is a lot to take in
and it's not easy to defend this pawn
you could play b3 but magnus wants to
avoid playing this um
b3 move as it further weakens the queen
side so rook h to d1 going after the d7
pawn but dude adjust the defensive and
still the c4 point is being threatened
so magnus goes knight to d2 defense
attacks the queen and well for the
moment he will not be playing b3 uh we
have queen back to f5 and now rook to f3
threatening some nasty discoveries
because the queen is on f5 but duda just
plays knight back to c6 and here uh he
really uh
makes magnus think because why would he
allow this for example bishop captures
an h6 just grabbing a pawn uh well it's
actually a very
very interesting idea magnus does
capture on h6 it is the best move in the
position and dude just plays knight to
d4 point being that if the queen is
captured then duda has this knight to e2
fork uh checking the king attacking the
queen and after the king moves we're
gonna capture the queen again with check
this will force white to triple his uh c
pawn and now for example he captures an
f5 and the black's position is just
better because uh even though you can
capture here it doesn't matter for
example rook h7 uh the the triple c pawn
is just disgusting here so instead after
knight to d4 magnus goes for queen
captures on d4 uh we have queen captures
on f3 so duda wins the exchange knight
captures on f3 c captures on d4 and now
bishop captures and g7 we have rook to
h7 attacking the bishop and bishop to f6
now the bishops get traded off as well
we have captures captures rook to h6 it
goes after the pawn magnus captures on
d4 duda captures an f6 and magnus now
plays f4
and this is the position that we have on
move 27 uh where magnus is down the
exchange but he is up two pawns now what
can dude do to get his rooks uh into the
game well it's very unlikely that you
will be able to break through on the
queen side uh magnus can just play b3
and you are not getting through b5 is
not happening the knight covers that so
your best bet is to go after the g3 pawn
but it's also very very easy for magnus
to defend this here we have king e7 duda
prepares to go after the pawn rook to d3
magnus already defends it we have rook
to c8 first putting pressure on this
pawn b3 defending it and now rook to g6
and now as the g3 pawn will get
attacked one more time magnus defends it
preemptively knights to e2 we have rook
seat the g8 and now just king to d2 so
for the moment the duda cannot do
anything here the knight nicely defends
the g3 pawn and magnus will even bring
the king over to f3 so he can
further activate his rook so d6 and now
a4 by magnus we have e5 trying to open
up the position uh we have rook to f3 uh
we have rooked the g4 by duda and now
king to e3 so uh for the moment the
position is fine for both players a
magnus has six minutes and the clock
duda is already below three minutes and
if you for example trade here captures
captures captures and captures uh it's
again just a position where white will
be the one that's pushing he has the
past h pawn and it's not gonna be easy
for black to stop this and the white is
still up two pawns so instead after king
e3 we have king to e6 now comes king to
f2 adding another defender here while
still asking black what are you gonna
play even though he does have two rooks
they are completely useless here uh we
have rook to g7 uh rook to e3 now we
have king to f5 getting the king away
from the e file and rook to d3 now
magnus goes after the d6 pawn we have
king back to e6 and now rook to d5 uh
with some ideas of maybe preparing a5 to
add
the bust open the queen side we have
rook to g8 and now king to f3 so this
row cannot move because this rook is
attacked we have a6 by duda and now if
magnus uh try some sort of a pawn push
then maybe uh for example a5 we can play
b5
but here we have rook back to d1 by
magnus interestingly you could play f5
here and it's uh it's a very nice idea
uh because if captures we're going to
capture on d6 and now okay we're going
after those pawns for example rook to g6
we can play rook to d7 and it's and it's
not an easy for a position for black to
be in for example rook to f6 would
defend the pawn there are even tricks
with knight to f4 so this is uh
what's in the position but even after
for example captures we're gonna play
rook d5 check kick the black king away
from the defense of the rook king e6
king captures on g4
let's say f3 it's very unlikely that the
white will be able to push for more than
a draw here
in a rapid game for example rook to d1
now king e5 and it's uh well it is just
looking very very
well drawish at the moment so instead
after this a6 move magnus goes back we
have rook to d1 now we have kinked the
e7 and only now magnus advances this
pawn to f5
we have rook four to g seven uh and this
is a move that duda should not have
played because now uh the position is
winning for magnus uh but it's uh it's a
tricky one so feel free to pause the
video here and win the game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on figuring out it's
the move you should almost never play
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course pawn to
f6 check that's the good stuff and now
of course after the king captures we're
gonna capture here and after king e7
we're going to capture on b6 and now our
position will be winning yes black will
play rook to g6 but we're going to play
rogue b7 check then bring our knight
into the game and uh well we're just
gonna be much much better here and uh
not only that we can create a lot of
past pawns here on the queen side uh
black will not be able to take care of
all of this so instead uh magnus did not
go for this he played rook to d5 which
allowed the duda a brief moment where he
could have played a little bit better
for example with king to d7 uh but duda
played king to f6 and he basically ran
into the same line only with a bit of a
more active king so here rook captures
on d6 was played king captures an f5
rook captures on v6 rook to g6 not
allowing the magnus to capture the a6
pawn as well
but now just a5 and it's a
uh tough to capture the rook because if
characters capture so let's say go after
rook we just play c5 we have two
connected past pawns of course
completely winning for magnus so after
a5 we have rook to d8
uh and now g for check uh really a tough
uh move to face for duda because the
king is completely cut off you don't
have a move uh and you have to accept
the g4 pawn uh so he captures it but not
knight g3 check and if you don't want to
give up a rook for nothing because these
two squares are taken uh you have to
capture the knight so rook captures king
captures now e4 duda starts pushing his
pass pawn now rook captures an a6 we
have king e5 uh rook to b6 we have
rooked the g8 with check
king to f2 now f5 dude is ready to push
f4 e3 uh but magnus is also pushing we
have a6 king to f4 uh now comes rook to
e6 not allowing duda to advance this
pawn to e3
so rook to g7 and now just c5 we have
rook to d7 trying to get a check in uh
but rook to d6 again uh rooks cannot be
traded off because these pawns are just
too strong so after work the d6 dude
goes back rook to g7 now rook to d4
magnus still doesn't allow a d3 check so
king to e5 and now rook to a4 with all
of these uh
moves magnus puts the rook behind the
pass pawn and now a7 a8 will win the
game it doesn't even matter if sorry if
you play rook to a7 yes you block the
pass pawn but i mean just b4 b5 b6 and
we win black uh does not have support to
push these uh these two pawns so instead
after rook a4 we have f4 by duda but now
a7 we have e3 check king to f1 and now
duda just played king to d1 but i don't
think he even played that i think his
time ran out on the clock and then he
just put the king somewhere maybe he was
just holding it in his hand but the
position is uh of course completely lost
regardless of what duda plays
and this is the final position of the
game interestingly it's a forced
checkmate in six moves the magnus can
bring a queen into the game and you
don't really have uh
well a lot of a lot of squares that you
can use you can play king captures on c5
we're going to play rook to c for check
and after let's say king d6 queen to c6
checking out it's very straightforward
king b7 rook to e4 check king to f7
queen to e6 check and after the king
moves king if uh sorry king of fate
we're going to deliver checkmate here or
any other uh you know series of moves
but uh yeah there's really nothing after
king to d5 the last move registered
magnus wins which means that uh after
nine rounds of the uh world rapids
championship because you know we had
five rounds the first day but only four
rounds on the second day and we're also
only going to have four rounds on the
third day it's magnus carlsen in seoul
lead uh with um
with eight uh out of nine i believe uh
let me just check that one more time no
with seven and a half out of nine uh
followed by uh three people and seven
points alexander richook north abdul
satoru and janipanishi so i don't know
if the pairings are out yet it doesn't
seem so
probably some some of the players are
still playing but as magnus already
faced grishok it will be either magnus
versus abu satoru or magnus versus
nipple so we might see a return clash
from the world chess championship match
the first the game the two of them
have
well will play uh after the world
championship so it's going to be very
interesting and tomorrow will be um well
just a very very very uh tiresome day
for all of them and we'll see if magnus
can continue pushing uh with this uh
strength even uh in the in the last day
because so far uh pretty much everything
has been going his way and it was a
little bit dangerous against alexander
grishoug but
in the end he
he
did not allow grisha to grab a full
point
uh so yeah that's the game tough break
for duda but um you know a nice one for
magnus i would like to thank uh czech uh
czechmate uh epilepsy catherine
matriarch uh jack schroeder uh jeffrey
redinor and uh david kimura for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day